what is with this accent what
what is happening right now sorry
who do you think i am
what do you mean who what's wrong with
you mark
what did you just call me
what's up everybody carlos here the
first episode of moonlight has finally
arrived on disney plus giving us an
intriguing new superhero story that
breaks the mold in many ways and i want
to talk about some of my favorite things
in this first episode now if you haven't
seen it yet we're not going to get too
spoilery here but if you want in on
everything we're talking about make sure
you go watch the show
my body wants to get up
and wander about you know like it has to
get the ten thousand steps in
you know
i don't even know about it until i wake
up wherever that's why i'm trying to
stay awake or not maybe unexpected but
can i say i'm actually digging the
accent
let me explain as divisive as the accent
has been since its reveal if you take
into account oscar isaac saying that
it's about some of stephen grant's
believed heritage and not an idea of
what brits actually sound like we start
to get a clearer idea of why he sounds
the way he does steven is a personality
invented through mark spectre's
dissociative identity disorder so it
makes sense that steven might have a
perfectly imperfect accent an acting
choice that puts more distance between
these two characters that inhabit the
same body it's a character choice that
could lead to interesting things down
the road isaac actually opened up about
actors he looked to for inspiration when
crafting it and i have to say
i did not think russell brandt was going
to be on the list i looked at a few
things um i think just from an energy
standpoint and a humor standpoint the
first way in was carl pilkington
um you know just the idea of
you know someone a fish out of water
situation i found that like and just his
dry sense of humor where you don't you
don't know if he knows he's being funny
i thought that was really important uh
russell kane a comedian who has a
similar background you know uh jewish
from from from a similar part of london
that i imagine stephen was from uh kind
of enfield kind of
vibe
and then yeah just different different
places a little bit of russell brand but
you know not quite as loquacious i'd say
[Music]
this chaos in you
it's not always a sure thing that a
great actor will make a great super
villain but ethan hawk kills it here as
arthur harrow in his scenes as the cult
leader he is equal parts sinister and
sincere making for a villain who at
least at this early point
easily outclasses our hero
hiya
mercenary mercenary no no i'm not a
mercery now i'm a gift shopist
i work at a gift shop um my name's
steven grant
one thing i really like about this
episode is that it doesn't really tell
you what's going on here as a viewer
you're about as confused as steven is
most of the time and it's an exciting
place to be as a lifelong comic fan i
often think i know where the story of a
screen adaptation is headed which can
become a game of like how close do they
get to the source material but with
marvel having a pretty great track
record of character reinvention and moon
knight's comic origins not being as set
in stone as other more well-known heroes
this show is giving everyone a chance to
be surprised
[Music]
well how did you all like the first
episode of moonlight if you're a die
hard fan how much would you say they've
gotten right so far and if you're new to
the character did this episode give you
enough to get you hooked let's talk
about it in the comments below and i'll
see you next time
you